best advice I would give somebody
starting out as an entrepreneur would be
find the smartest person or the most
accomplished person that will take you
seriously work from them work for them
for free and just see everything that
you can learn my name is Matt Humphrey
co-founder and CEO lending home and I'm
29 years old
lending home is the best way to get a
mortgage we've reengineered the process
from end and starting with technology to
make it really simple fast and reliable
for anyone anywhere to be able to get a
mortgage and we also make it very easy
for investors to invest in those
mortgages as well
it's amazing for such a big industry
it's still predominantly offline
physical retail branches paper so
bringing it online making it fast where
you can close in a matter of days or
weeks not months expand the access to
credit where today you know a huge
percentage of customers even credit
worthy ones in the u.s. don't
technically qualify again we fix that
problem and really make the single most
important purchase decision that ever
that a customer is ever going to make
make that process hassle-free and really
simple
I was actually looking for a simple and
transparent way to invest into real
estate and mortgage and when I didn't
find anything and kind of perked my
jerked my attention and digging into the
actual process and learning as somebody
who didn't know much about the industry
learning just how of old school and what
a lack of technology there was we
thought there was a way we could do this
better and so back in 2013 kicked off
the company with the ambition of saying
you know to rebuild a Borders Bank from
the ground up with technology take a
significant effort really rebuilding
every piece of that value chain so we re
raise some money spend six or seven
months heads down building this next
generation experience and then
ultimately started lending about two and
a half years ago
[Music]
the first three companies that I founded
starting when I was seventeen we weight
a group of college buddies and I built
our first our first venture you know
each of those first three or four didn't
work out at all right we either be that
the technology didn't quite function the
way we thought or we picked a bad market
but we were able to rebound from each of
those and we learn something each time
and so I'm a big believer that you're
gonna make a bunch of mistakes in life
make each one once learn that lesson
move on and so I think you know when
we're building something this complex
this fast with this amount of growth you
know it's good to be not making all
those mistakes for the first time and
have a few few failed startups under the
belt to earn the stripes
[Music]
you